the college is operating at a great peak
right now we dedicated our chapel we
celebrated one hundred and seventy fifth
anniversary we're having a fantastic
year in every respect students are great
it's an amazingly happy campus and we
reach more people than ever and so those
are all blessings and here they
disrupted what to do about this depends
upon two things and one is the personal
health of the members of the campus
community they divide into students whom
we must protect first and staff who
however are more vulnerable to this than
the students and of course they can get
it from the students and and so we have
to think about the staff too we're not
inviting the students back to campus yet
we're very reluctant to make that just a
decision and that's because what we do
here is valuable I mean it's beautiful
to me it's what sustains me in my career
for a long time now and to all of us
here we get to think and talk together
in friendship about the best things and
there is a disruption of that and that
is very bad and don't mistake that it's
not very bad and that's why I promise
you the minute it's safe we're gonna go
back to that I'll just close with the
story about how inspiring it is there
are these roughly 50 kids there about a
hundred kids 150 men about 150 I think
kids on campus leaving the home for
spring break
50 of them are in a spring break
alternative they call it their doing
mission work around town helping the
poor and all kinds of projects they're
sleeping on the floor of the First
Methodist Church and they're eating
spaghetti that they cooked themselves at
night kids
you know so I called them all in and we
talked for an hour and a half about all
this and I told them what I know about
it and I asked questions and I let them
answer I asked them questions they ask
me questions they proposed plans they
said dr. Arnn
we have to get the students back here as
fast as we can this is what we do and we
never get another chance to do this and
we can take care of each other I mean it
was a clamor it was wonderful I mean I
it made me cry now
we didn't do what they said right and we
feel small because of it we did the
right thing but we didn't do the noblest
thing and doesn't it matter so much that
the students here know what the noblest
thing is and wish to servant even at
risk to themselves that is the
preparation for a good life the best
possible preparation and we get that
here it is such a blessing I promise you
we're going to fight to preserve it and
to keep your kids safe